a ten-year-old boy in Florida has become
one of the youngest victims of the
national opioid epidemic
investigators say Alton banks died last
month after he came in contact with the
powerful painkiller fentanyl but how the
fifth grader was exposed is still a
mystery
Omar Villafranca is in Miami's Overton
neighborhood where the boy lived Omar
good morning good morning
Alton's mother described her son as a
fun kid he loved the Carolina Panthers
and wanted to be an engineer but here in
Overtown detectives are just trying to
find out how he came in contact with a
deadly mix of fentanyl and heroin
Alton banks final days seem to be a
carefree one summer vacation playing at
the community pool but when the ten year
old got home he started throwing up his
mother later found him unresponsive in
his room and called 9-1-1 he was
pronounced dead at the hospital
toxicologist found the powerful
painkiller fentanyl in his system we
don't know where he got it
we don't believe at this point it was in
his home Katherine Fernandez Rundle is
the Miami Dade State Attorney
she says Altan likely came in contact
with the drug at the pool or on his walk
home to think that this Gerdes this
synthetic drug has hit our streets and
now is going to be killing our innocent
children his neighborhood is one of the
many communities ravaged by opioids in
South Florida alone an overdose occurs
every two hours just how powerful is the
drug the tiny specks in this vial are
enough to be lethal the thought of his
cocaine Ohio police officer chris green
suffered an accidental overdose from
street fentanyl in May following a drug
bust
he was hospitalized and survived this
drug has no mercy on it doesn't care who
you are if you're dead doctor para map
de Carrie is a nephrologist in Florida's
Broward County he says fentanyl can be
absorbed in the body as easily as making
contact with the skin this is just
touching breathing being around smoking
around and this is what makes it so
scary
the medical examiner's office says last
year in the Miami area there were nearly
300 overdose deaths involving different
forms of fentanyl
but drug dealers have been put on notice
there's a florida law that goes into
effect coming up in october that would
allow drug dealers to be charged with
murder if they're caught dealing a fatal
dose of fentanyl or any drug mixed with
fentanyl charlie thanks Omar